Y
CAMPAIGN AGAINST HAMAS
MILITANTS AND GAZA, NOW ADDING
ARTILLERY FIRE TO, IT'S
PUNISHING AIRSTRIKES.
THE IDF SAYS, NO ISRAELI TROOPS
ARE INSIDE OF GAZA, CLARIFYING
A STATEMENT THAT WAS MADE
EARLIER BY THEM.
AND, ALTHOUGH IT IS CONSIDERING
A GROUND ENCOURAGING, ANY
DECISION WOULD TAKE DAYS.
ISRAEL, WARNING RESIDENTS NEAR
THE BORDER WITH GAZA, TO REMAIN
INSIDE THEIR SHELTERS.
TO THE NORTH, ROCKETS FIRING
FROM GAZA, CONTINUING TO LAND,
INDISCRIMINATELY IN TEL AVIV,
AND OTHER CITIES.
AT LEAST 7 ISRAELIS HAVE BEEN
KILLED.
THE IDF SAYS, IT'S IRON DOME
AERIAL DEFENSIVE SYSTEM HAS
INTERCEPTED 90% OF THE INCOMING
MISSILES.
INSIDE OF GAZA, THE DEATH TOLL
FROM ISRAELI AIRSTRIKES HAS
CLIMBED, IN THE LAST HOUR.
IT 119 PEOPLE, INCLUDING 31
CHILDREN.
STILL, ISRAEL CLAIMS IT IS
GOING TO GREAT LENGTHS TO AVOID
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES.
THE LATEST TARGETS, INCLUDING
AN ALLEGED MISSILE PRODUCTION
SITE, AND A HAMAS NAVAL
FACILITY, AS WELL AS THE HOMES
OF TO TOP HAMAS COMMANDERS.
PRIME MINISTER, BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU, SAYING THE STRIKES
ON GAZA ARE FAR FROM OVER.
>> THE DEFENSE ACTIVITY OF IRON
DOME BATTERIES, GIVING US AN
OFFENSIVE CASE, AND THE ISRAELI
DEFENSE FORCES ATTACKING
HUNDREDS OF TARGETS, SOON
PASSING 1000.
WE STRIKE A, MUSCLE DEFENDING
OUR CITIZENS.
IT WILL TAKE MORE TIME, WITH
GREAT FIRMNESS AN OFFENSE, AS
WELL AS DEFENSE, WE ACHIEVE OUR
GOAL OF BRINGING BACK HOME TO
THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
>> MR. NETANYAHU, ALSO
CONDEMNING THE WAVE OF MOB
VIOLENCE, SPREADING THROUGH
CITIES, AND TOWNS, ACROSS
ISRAEL.
HE IS GRANTING POLICE EMERGENCY
POWERS TO IMPOSE CURFEWS,
STOPPING ONE OF THE ONGOING
CLASHES BETWEEN ARAB, AND
JEWISH CITIZENS, WHO HAVE LIVED,
QUITE PEACEFULLY, SIDE BY SIDE
FOR DECADES.
CNN'S HADAS GOLD, REPORTS FROM
JERUSALEM.
>> ALSO, MOHSEN ISRAELI
MILITARY WHICH BATTLE OF THE
SKIES OVER ISRAEL, AND GAZA,
TENSIONS ARE ESCALATING.
WITH THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT,
DOWNPLAYING THE PROSPECT OF AN
IMMEDIATE CEASE FIRE.
>> IF WE CEASE-FIRE RIGHT NOW,
HUMMUS WILL GET TO ITS GOAL,
AND ITS OBJECTIVE, OF HITTING
ISRAEL, AND NOT PAYING A PRICE.
WE WILL ATTACK THE HAMAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> BACK ON THE GROUND, AN
ALARMING LEVEL OF RAGE,
SPILLING INTO THE STREETS
BEYOND JERUSALEM.
MOB VIOLENCE, SPREADING THROUGH
MIXED ARAB, AND JEWISH CITIES.
>> I SAW DEATH, DEATH.
YOU KNOW A DEATH IS?
PEOPLE JUMPING AT YOU WAS
STONES, THROWING STONES AT ME.
>> ARAB CITIZENS, ATTACKING A
MAN, THEY THINK IS JEWISH.
JEWISH CITIZENS, ATTACKING
SOMEONE, THEY BELIEVE, IS ARAB.
THE COMMUNAL VIOLENCE, REACHING
SUCH A FEVER PITCH, ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER, BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU, ANGRILY WARNING
ROGUE VIGILANTES TO STOP, OR
FACE DIRE CONSEQUENCES.
>> I DO NOT CARE AT ALL IF YOUR
BLOOD IS BOILING.
IT'S BOILING, AND IT'S AN
INTERESTING.
YOU CANNOT TAKE THE LAW INTO
YOUR OWN HANDS.
YOU CANNOT TAKE A SIMPLE ARAB
CITIZEN, IN ATTEMPT TO LYNCH
HIM.
JUST AS WE CANNOT SEE ARAB
CITIZENS DOING THIS TO JEWISH
CITIZENS, THIS WILL NOT STAND.
>> POLICE, GETTING
REINFORCEMENTS ON HORSEBACK, IN
RIOT GEAR, AND CITIES TO QUELL
THE UNREST.
AS SIRENS RING, CONSTANTLY, A
WARNING FROM ABOVE INCOMING
ROCKET FIRE.
THE IRON DOME, STOPPING 90% OF
THE MORE THAN 1800 ROCKETS
FIRED TO ISRAEL THUS FAR,
ACCORDING TO THE ISRAELI
MILITARY.
WITH ISRAELI AIR STRIKES
TARGETING HAMAS, AND ISLAMIC
JIHAD MILITANTS IN GAZA, THE
CASUALTY COUNT IS RISING, WITH
EACH EXCHANGE.
THE DISPLACED IN GAZA, GROWING,
WITH EVERY BUILDING REDUCED TO
RUBBLE.
THE THREAT IN THE SKIES, SO
GRAVE, THAT MANY WESTERN
AIRLINES HAVE CANCELED FLIGHTS
TO TEL AVIV.
AND, ON A NEW FRONT, HAMAS
RELEASING A SLICK PROPAGANDA
VIDEO, LAUNCHING, WHAT IT SAYS,
ARE SUICIDE DRONES.
DRONES THAT ISRAELI FORCES SAY,
THEY HAVE SHOT DOWN.
DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS UNDERWAY,
OVERSEAS, WITH NATIONS WEIGHING
IN ON THE CONFLICT, AND URGING
CALM.
WHILE IN TEL AVIV ELSEWHERE,
SCIENCE, POPPING UP URGING
PEACEFUL COEXISTENCE.
>> WE NEED TO LIVE HERE
TOGETHER.
COEXISTENCE.
WE NEED TO BE TOGETHER.
PARTNERS, TO BE PARTNERS WITH
EACH OTHER.
>> IN THE MEANTIME, THE BARRAGE
OF ROCKETS, ONGOING.
WHILE ALONG THE ISRAELI GAZA
BORDER, TANKS AND POSITION TAKE
AIM, AND FIRE.
HADAS GOLD, CNN, JERUSALEM.
>> AND JUST A BEST 10 AM IN TEL
AVIV, THE SOUTHERN OUTSKIRTS OF
THE CITY, THAT IS WHERE WE FIND
JOURNALIST, ELLIOTT GOT KIND.
LIVE FOR US THIS HOUR.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT THE
CHANCES OF WHAT THE SCOPE MIGHT
BE OF THE OPERATION GOING
FORWARD?
A SENSE OF HOW FAR THE IDF
MIGHT GO?
>> IT HAD PEOPLE GOING FORTH,
AND GOING UNDERWAY YESTERDAY,
WHEN THE IDF TWEETED OUT,
ISRAELI, AIR, AND GROUND FORCES,
WERE ATTACKING THE GAZA STRIP.
THAT WAS SWIFTLY CLARIFIED,
THERE WERE NO GROUND FORCES IN
THE GAZA STRIP YET.
THERE WERE 50 ROUNDS OF TANK
FIRE, AT THE IDF SAYS, AND LAST
NIGHT, WHAT THEY WERE DOING WAS
TARGETING THIS KIND OF
ELABORATE LABYRINTH OF TUNNELS,
THAT HAMAS, AND OTHER MILITANT
GROUPS, HAVE UNDERGROUND.
IT IS SEPARATE CITY, THE IDEA
OF CALLS, THE METRO.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO, IT'S
DESTROY THOSE TUNNELS, AND
IMPEDE THE MILITANT GROUPS
ABILITY TO MOVE ROCKETS AROUND,
OR TO TAKE COVER, AND TO EVADE
THE AIRSTRIKES, OR ARTILLERY
STRIKES, THAT ISRAEL WAS
RAINING DOWN, ON PARTS OF THE
GAZA STRIP.
IN TERMS OF THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE GROUND INCURSION, STILL, IT
IS ON THE TABLE.
IT WAS NEVER OFF THE TABLE, AND
IT DOES LOOK LIKE WE MAY BE
GETTING CLOSER TO THAT
EVENTUALITY, AND IT WAS COMING
UP, BUT THAT WOULD SUGGEST IF
THERE IS A GROUND INCURSION, IS
NOT LIKELY TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT FEW DAYS, FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
THE MILITARY REASON, THAT WHICH
IS A SINGLE DIVISION OF ARMORED
INFANTRY THERE, BY GAZA, AND
IT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE GROUND OPERATION
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THE POLITICAL REASON IS THAT
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU,
CLINGING TO OFFICE, BY THE SKIN
OF HIS TEETH.
IT LOOKS NOW, THE OPPOSITION
WILL BE UNABLE TO PUT TOGETHER
A GOVERNING COALITION.
WHICH MEANS, ANOTHER SET OF
ELECTIONS, IT'S ANOTHER, ONE IS
LIKELY LATER IN THE YEAR, WHICH
GIVES NETANYAHU ANOTHER CHANCE
OF BEING VERY MINDFUL THAT HIS
POPULARITY COULD BE SEVERELY
AFFECTED, AND IF THE GROUND
INCURSION GOES, AHEAD AND THERE
ARE ANOTHER NUMBER OF ISRAELI
CASUALTIES.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE
CASUALTIES IT WILL BE GOING
THROUGH HIS MIND, EVEN AS
PLANNING FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF
A GROUND INCURSION CONTINUES TO
ADVANCE.
>> THERE HAS BEEN ONE OTHER
WORRYING ASPECT OF WHAT HAS
BEEN HAPPENING, AND THAT IS
VIOLENCE IN SOME OF THESE
ISRAELI TOWNS, WITH MIXED
POPULATIONS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THERE
ARE OLD WOUNDS AND SOME OF
THESE PLACES.
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T SEEN
BEFORE.
>> THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
IS COMMON, YES THERE ARE
OCCASIONALLY TENSIONS, OR
ISOLATED INCIDENCES OF VIOLENCE,
BUT NOTHING ON THIS SCALE, AND
CERTAINLY NOT HAVING ISRAELI
ARABS, AND ISRAELI JEWS ATTACK
EACH OTHER, ON MICK CITIES, ON
WHAT SEEMS TO BE A NIGHTLY
BASIS.
JUST HERE, YESTERDAY, A 19 YEAR
OLD ISRAELI SOLDIER WAS
ATTACKED, AND SUFFERED A
FRACTURED SKULL.
HIS STATUS IN HOSPITAL, NO
STABLE.
AND, WE ALSO KNOW, THAT AS
HADAS WAS RELATING JUST BEFORE,
THERE WAS MORE ATTACK ON
ISRAELI ARAB CITIZENS, MORE BY
MOBS OF ISRAELI JEWS, AND
ISRAELI JEWISH MOBS, ATTACKING
ISRAELI ARAB CITIZENS.
THE PRESIDENT, PLEADING FOR THE
MADNESS, AND SAYING TO
NETANYAHU, THE PRIME MINISTER,
SAYING THERE ARE SEVERE
PENALTIES, AND ANARCHY WILL NOT
BE TOLERATED.
BUT, AS WE WORK TOGETHER, THERE
IS STILL CONCERNS THAT MORE
VIOLENCE MAYBE WORK TOGETHER,
AND CERTAINLY, AS A PARTIAL,
HERE AT THE ENTRANCE, THE
MANAGER TOLD US A FEW MINUTES
AGO, HE IS TELLING ALL GUESTS
TO LEAVE, AND CLOSING THE
HOTEL.
HE IS THAT CONCERNED ABOUT MORE
VIOLENCE TAKING PLACE, HERE, IN
THIS PART OF TEL AVIV.
>> WOW, THAT IS SOMETHING.